people of the internet retro wrecking
tour here and yes this right up here is
me this is the situation I was facing
look at that level 14. it's a Podium
opal eye two Death Eaters Malfoy gang
almost a 1 000 it's kind of hard to see
right there I think it was at 8 33
1785 almost a 1 000 HP difference here
and somehow I come back and win this
game Let's dive in and take a look at
the whole game and see exactly what
happened here okay first I just want to
show you what we were dealing with in
terms of levels here so I think we're
starting to hit the point where it's a
free-to-play player
I don't know if I'm gonna be able to
make Grand Masters guys I'm gonna keep
trying but we had a level 14 opal eye
over there my highest card is the level
10 plus one Hagrid I do have a level 10
thunderstorm but they've got level 12
level 11 level 10 level 12. but I mean
they're they're lowest level card level
10 is my highest level card level 10
plus one crucio just crazy
3464 total damage as you're gonna see
here in the fight
they also had the legendary Bellatrix
Echo so I really am beginning to wonder
guys if I'm actually going to be able to
make it all the way through to Grand
Master as a free-to-play player it's
tough man it's tough I've been trying to
level up my character as much as I can
but you know when when people are going
to spend a lot of money on the game
which is their right to do so it's tough
I just wish the PVP wasn't like this I
mean look at the start right there
3464 to 28.54 immediately throws the
stack of Monster books I do have an
incendio ready and then I go ahead and
get Cassandra out
so that was pretty nice right there we
weathered that early push he fires off
the incendio I'm not sure what that was
about I mean I guess just trying to
start put some damage on Cassandra I go
ahead and get the bomb box going with
the cats and then this was huge the
nebulous allows me to protect Cassandra
eat those out of thunderstorm and we
Dodge the first few uh bolts right there
because we were still in the nebulous
cloud and so Ron basically does nothing
I mean Ron didn't do anything for him
unfortunately he then throws the
atmospheric charm on Cassandra I guess I
could have uh
maybe walk through it myself to try to
pull some of the damage away from her
but
at that point it probably wasn't worth
it and then this was a bad spot for me
I missed the exploso missed the expulso
with the orb of water then they get out
the Death Eater I know they don't have
nebulous at this point so I throw
Hermione throw the double thunderstorm
and I'm just hoping please take out that
Death Eater and finally it does
again kind of a strange incendio right
there you'll see you'll see another
weird incendio here in a second and then
this is bad positioning by me
bad positioning letting my Death Eater
spawn right in the middle of Cassandra's
ring and you could just see how powerful
she is as a companion I mean she just
instantly takes it out I go and cast
nebulous just to give myself a little
bit of HP
they throw the atmosphere charm which
again kind of a odd play right there
I hit exploso just to kind of bump
Cassandra back a little bit and you can
see that they made me pay
because then they knew I don't have
expulso let me cast orb of water they
were trying to pull me into Cassandra
fortunately
the lightning bolt finally took her out
then we get another stack of Monster
books so I've got a bomb box to draw
some attention away incendio ready and
then this is from the screenshot right
here look at this moment so I've got a
few cats over there doing some work he's
got the monster book over doing work on
me but then right here
I thought the monster book just to give
me something we've got two Death Eaters
Malfoy gang
and then the antipody and opal eye
Hagrid I pull them out just to get a
little bit of extra HP I throw the the
bomb box because I know I've got my
Death Eaters coming
and then look at this man look at this
Hagrid prevents us from getting caught
in the orb
and right here this is where the game
changed look at this they still have
nearly a 1000 HP
right there why did they cast the
incendio on me
they could have eat the Death Eaters
were Side by look look at their health
I I don't understand we're and then we
we gotta watch that part again I I don't
understand
what they what they were doing right
there the Death Eaters are right
together the thing about the Death
Eaters guys they do not have a lot of
Health I mean one incendio on both of
them and they're done here's the only
thing that I can think of and let me
move my webcam down just a little bit so
you guys can see you can see what's
going on up here with me right up in
here but the only thing I could think of
there is a shortcut if you want to
instantly cast a spell instead of
clicking and dragging you can actually
double tap on that spell if you're
playing on a PC you can double click
and this is actually really handy in a
lot of situations whenever you need to
cast something that it doesn't matter
specifically where it goes
thunderstorm for example you know you
can double click that
and it will instantly cast the only
thing I can think of here is that they
have gotten so used to doing that type
of cast
and the thing about it when you have
multiple enemies on the field
I'm not sure how it judges where it
wants to go so I mean they could have I
don't know that they would have won the
battle
but you can see how fast the Death
Eaters start to melt their health so for
whatever reason this moment right here
if I was in this situation if you're in
this situation and you have these two
Death Eaters
they are your priority even if I'm at
871 HP I mean there's no way he thought
he could have finished me off right
there surely not with one incendio
but
they fire the incentive over me I easily
walk out of it and then
then the Death Eaters do what they do
they do what they do
they just absolutely melt
I get a thunderstorm I mean
a thousand HP difference just
obliterated in a second so yet again
this showing off the power of the
Bellatrix deck in PvP if you guys want
to know more about the deck that I used
that got me all the way to Diamond then
check out the video on the right side of
your screen next as always thank you all
so much for watching I'll talk to you
again soon